how is this feel because allegedly this
is the end for this group how does this
feel ending something that i mean it's
been an iconic franchise you know it
feels it feels really good it feels like
um it's made all the better by the fact
that the movie is so good and that the
story lines are so surprising and
fulfilling and you're taking you know
you're watching the end of the arc that
started 30 years ago with these
characters from jurassic park sam neil
laura dern jeff goldblum bd wong like
this thing really has come full circle
and the characters that we started in
jurassic world
you're seeing the where those characters
have evolved and continue to go to and
will go to and so it's it feels it feels
fantastic
genetic power has now been unleashed
we made a terrible mistake
the doomsday clock might be about out of
time
[Music]
i heard just tell me whether it's true
or not you know people put all kinds of
things on the internet the first kiss
you guys ever had in jurassic world was
a surprise so yes and no
it it wasn't a surprise to me
it it was a surprise to everyone who was
there that day because it wasn't written
here's a little a little thing to know
about me i'm always vying to kiss
chris pratt in these movies and
and this the dominion was the only time
that there's actually been a kiss
written into the movie right the last
two we sneakily stole that's right yeah
that's right because it's okay to have a
little romance in a draft movie yeah
it's the first thing you learn in improv
yes and yes you know you throw a kiss
all right
let's go
and it works it works
come on you're married you're old
married couple mouth you know yeah it's
true it's true the the sort of
the need for the will they won't they
sexual chemistry does not fall on us in
this film it's laura and sam yeah and
i'm telling you
red hot
that's true it's true red hot it's true
we were there when they kissed remember
that
they're right but they might kill you
who knows who knows i'm telling you
it's it's a kiss 30 years in the making
it's like you want you want that you
know they didn't and and it's just
fantastic it's so beautiful bryce you're
a director now has that changed the way
you are as an actor too well you know
what i
cause i was so lucky to get to have
access to movie sets as a little kid and
because my dad was a child actor he
thought it was really appropriate to
bring your kids to set he's like oh yeah
kid's on set that makes sense so i and
they usually kind of kept me away from
the actors because you know they're like
focusing and all that kind of stuff like
they don't need to like deal with a
little red etiquette so my experience of
a movie set has always been
through the lens of the director
and it it was kind of odd for me when i
first started making movies like i would
go to video village and i would like sit
in the director's like chair
and and then i'd be like oh my god wait
no this is not my dad's chair like a
dance in the director's chair
and because that was like the the habit
so getting to
direct um you know more more
consistently the last several years has
been absolutely wonderful and i've
certainly learned so so much but for me
acting was kind of more of a like that
was sort of like i wonder what this is
going to be like whereas directing felt
more familiar it's worked out for you
you know you know it's worked out will
you are you gonna miss this are you
gonna miss the dinosaurs i mean yeah i
think so i i you know i don't miss the
dinosaurs baby raptor i made a promise
we would bring her home
you made a promise
to a dinosaur
yeah what
everybody hold on to somebody
that can't be right
what is that biggest carnivore the world
has ever seen
here's my bigger question how many
dinosaurs can you name off the top of
your head can you just rattle through
dinosaurs now yeah for sure
yeah oh yeah
yeah oh really i'm certainly going to
miss this to the first question yeah i'm
going to miss this but yeah i mean we
could i could just talk about the 30
dinosaurs that we have in this film we
got t-rex
we've got quetzalcoatlus we've got
giganotosaurus velociraptor atrocious
raptor pyro raptor uh we've got the uh i
believe toronto dom we've got the
pterodam we've got the new pseudosaurus
we've got the chris i trust you i trust
you i trust you now i trust you i
believe you also this has been a moment
where you guys have had a chance to kind
of you grow up together when you do this
many movies together and and what has
that been like watching your families
grow and living your lives and then
coming back together what's that been
like the best because
chris is someone who i respect and
admire and have a blast with and we're
just we're very
we're very compatible as that is true as
team members honestly as co-workers and
uh and you know very kind of similar
similar ages and all of that and so
getting to have a friend like you in my
life has been absolutely amazing and
that doesn't go away which is good true
you know we don't get to see each other
just at work
but but the friendship doesn't die which
is wonderful
i promise you i am gonna get her back
bryce is actually the secret weapon i
think she operates in the shadows like a
ninja all right i'm not i'm not kidding
you should see the journal she has kept
since the beginning uh or at least from
jurassic world until now how much
how many ideas were mined from this
journal she's like a gentle application
of pressure
to to affect literally everything around
her so you asked a question about her as
a director she's always been a director
whether she's been the director or
someone
directing the flow
in a very
subtle manner but effective and
ultimately like pays off in the end like
uh has a profound impact on the quality
of the piece but never standing up there
to take all the credit for it like she's
the secret weapon and if you're anybody
making a movie and you have the
opportunity to have her involved in any
way you absolutely do it you do it
because it'll be it'll be better in the
end because of her involvement i also
want to ask you you know your wife was a
correspondent for us back in the day
i think it's interesting that uh my
generation focuses a lot on being happy
in a job which is according to my mother
is just not at all what your generation
is my generation wasn't be happy my
generation was get a job that you can
support yourself it was of course great
and just you knew then how smart she's
so dag on smart [ __ ] she could easily
take this job but she has bigger things
i
wouldn't how many kids cuz she's
pregnant again how many kids you guys
going for i mean you're not messing
around dude i yeah dozens
dozens we want to have one dozen
children i mean chris we were just
talking about this he's always he's
always really wanted a big family
and um and i'm from a big family so i
absolutely love that and i love that for
you yeah it's gonna be a big summer
[Music]
you